l'animatrice accueillera sera les
nominés sont
dans la catégorie awards de l'animatrice
sera sera les nommés sont anne sophie
lapix pour son arrogance envers ses
invités s'ils n'étaient pas aujourd'hui
le mieux placé on sait que je serai
devant vous ce soir pour expliquer mais
pour l'instant vous n'êtes même pas au
second tour un dans les sondages
karine le marchand qui pose plus de
questions que votre belle-mère dîner de
famille enfin qu'est ce qui t'a dit ton
fils raté partie comment ça tu es
surpris de me voir comment tu te sens
bon alors comment est-ce que tu aperçu
la diffusion de son portrait elise lucet
qui visiblement ne travaillera jamais
chez bfm télé les commentateurs
d'actualité en fait moi ça m'intéresse
pas j'ai envie de voir des vrais gens et
j'ai pas envie que ce soit des gens
lisses qui devant une caméra raconte la
vie des gens comme si c'était des
sociologues en train de regarder avec
une loupe les gens qui s'agitent en bas
je m'agace elle dit qui nous avait caché
ses talons d'animatrice
[Musique]
rêver la considération que me porte
l'équipe de production sont régalés
l'asie en animatrice un pur asra des
animatrices sympathique ira sera en plus
de 100 m à berlin à trois et quatre mois
non alors écoutez oui allez-y ok alors
moi c'est karine le marchand
et doper un peu quand même j'ai passé un
sujet un assez bon gentil parce qu'on
dirait qu'elle est gentil comme ça et
que l adapter les choses et evra en
france
l epita m bah en fait moi quand j'ai
fait mes interviews avec les candidats à
la présidentielle je sais pas ce qui lui
a pris un jour en radio elle a dit y a
qu un quinqua diamé a mais c'est un peu
le même si elle a pompé karine le
marchand est forte parce qu'elle faisait
des interviews aussi en politique alors
aux tendances mais c'était chez les gens
moi c'était une immersion avec candidats
un aventurier pas dans leur intimité moi
je n'avais rien à voir et à 10 n'ont pas
pomper c'est pas moi qu'à la pompe et
vous inquiétez pas genre un pseudo sympa
oui et en fait et en fait je trouve que
de femme à femme c'est c'est lamentable
donc là que pour ça je lui met un zéro à
-20 et 1 - 1 - sens voilà très bien
que ça se fait pas je trouve parce que
ce n'est pas mon vécu et c'est pas comme
j'étais enfin comment j'ai travaillé
pour faire les cheveux c'est pas bien
deborah alors moi c'est que je peux pas
plaire c'est élise lucet a on est
quelques-uns alors élise lucet je trouve
que de plus en plus politisée à la base
elle est censée être enfin être
journaliste être neutre et c'est devenu
le pantin de la france insoumise je peux
plus voir ça hier c'était lundi soir
elle a bien un tweet en disant oui
l'importance de la redevance tv etc
parce que la redevance et va peut-être
être supprimés elle a appelé tous les
français à
voter pour maintenir la redevance télé
rappelons quand même que cette dame
touche 25000 euros par mois et que la
redevance télé sert surtout à veiller
salaires
donc je la trouve de plus en plus à 1000
euros par mois ce qui était annoncé
encore une fois c'est elles apprennent à
confirmer oui mais elle a beaucoup
publié il ya les chats la
conductrice est peut-être plus ben oui
pour ça qu'on peut dire que oui après
enquête
à trouve hyper politisé je ne vous en
veux pas a lancé par rapport à la
redevance parce que les redevances et
les documentaires c'est la fiction que
tu regardais déjà payé quelque chose
alors que pas obligé de radés france
télé c'est ça qui est un peu chez nous
on nous oblige à payer une redevance
pour voir 50 fois les mêmes reportages
sur les musulmans qui sont la cause de
toute l'année de toutes les peines dans
le monde sur elle qui vient qui
s'incruste dans des bureaux tu ferme la
porte elle a atterri par la fenêtre je
ferme la fenêtre dans les idées
je ne peux plus un peu plus vous grâce
et les nigauds nigauds vous ai travaillé
avec une liste de ces ou non j'ai pas
travailler directement avec elle mais en
tout cas dernièrement vous savez qu'elle
a pris position contre les chaînes
d'information trouvé extrêmement mépris
nouri timing avec ses collègues emploi
très mauvais timing effectivement il y
avait ce journaliste mais
tu es en ukraine donc je ne comprends
pas son positionnement puisque d'un côté
elle veut effectivement dénoncé beaucoup
de choses avec cash investigations qui
pour moi n'est pas une mauvaise émission
et qui permet l'émission car il
est en train de moins attrayant je parle
du début de l'émission mais là elle est
en train de monter d'un cran je la
trouve méprisante et je trouve surtout
un peu reine du monde on a l'impression
que rien ne peut l'accrocher sur
lesquels peu à l'état plaisir sur monde
et c'est quoi ces cas-là enfoncer des
portes ouvertes excusez moi elle assuré
le début le début était pas là il m'a
fait rester un cas ça mais ces questions
sur le service public jamais
sur laquelle il ya eu une évolution dans
cash investigations au début de
l'émission l'émission était plutôt pas
mal au démarrage après elle est partie
dans des directions et en plus c'est
très compliqué parce qu'elle est quand
même sur le service public même s'il ya
plus de pub après 20 heures l'accord de
la publicité et elle pose un vrai
problème là encore en prenant position
par exemple sur la redevance elle est en
train de faire de la politique à
l'intérieur du service public donc pour
moi ça devient très compliqué c'était de
vie médias par ses méthodes ses méthodes
moi je les trouve très contestable je
déteste son côté un peu paparazzi un peu
à la rive je vais sauver le monde est en
fait à chaque fois à utiliser des
méthodes qui sont vraiment vraiment à la
limite du légal moi je la trouve pas
sympathiques je trouve guère est un être
humain comme swatch à saint pierre qui
interpelle le papier photo vient ici
pour le poser non mais séoul être
animatrice échappe c'est quand même
rassemblé c'est quand même être
fédérateur quand on parle des
animatrices qu'on aime c'est des gens
qui rassemble des gens qui sourient
regardez-vous les gens vous aiment et
bienveillant joyeux elle chausse de
voler
ils vont vous et il les sent pas il est
il et voilà j'en ai mis à l'amendé assez
sympa oui mais
benjamin castaldi l'émission c'est un
animal c'est pas ça que je
maîtrise ma
politique allez c'est pas plus en plus
elle veut se venger comme étant une
animatrice qui fait des blagues qui fait
des mises en scène elle a fait une
parodie les petits maillots enfin
surtout sauveuse du monde un peu
jean-michel quand elle interpelle quand
même le pas à l'époque elle est d'une
manière mais c'est irrespectueux c'est
scandaleux mais le connais depuis
longtemps apparemment et vous ou michele
moi j'adore anne sophie lapix et les
trois autres oui donc vous n'aimez 10 du
6 mai j'ai tellement d'idées je veux pas
me répéter
karine lemarchand je me suis déjà aussi
feuilleter avec elle parce que c'est une
diva est moulé diva c'est pas parce
qu'on fait la télévision qu'on va avoir
un melon comme ça donc j'aime pas trop
et le troisième se met sa main cassagnac
dessin non maintenant avocat stage
l'adorent cosmo show dont je suis gay ni
rien à dire ce qu'est le marchand qui
est comme l'animatrice qui fait le plus
d'audience tu serais de la télévision et
jetez la matrice l'élève le plus
d'audience avec l'amour est dans le pré
je ne peux supposerait à mon regard sur
elle
[Applaudissements]
non pas pour ses interventions dans
catch investigations parce qu'à chaque
fois où elle intervient alors à la
gauche ou par la droite elle a déjà
envoyé des mails elle veut contacter les
gens mais c'est par rapport à sa sortie
par rapport à bfmtv en lisons que ce
sont des journalistes de pacotille je
trouve ça assez irrespectueux
donc on est d'accord on le donne à l'isu
ces voix là bas et ici tu ne regardes
c'est pour toi entendre à ce que je
pense
j'étais je les croisais à roland garros
voilà elle m'a vu à tout vous dire
qu'elle a c'est vrai ah oui elle est
soumise
en train de faire un reportage sur rien
du tout rire du tout